citizens of the reject nation greg here today
today i'm going to share with you all my 10
most unpopular movie opinions the only way i can
describe this list is by the films i get the most
crap for when i admit that i actually like them or
that i don't actually like them so that is what my
ranking is comprised of so no to get this out of
the way i'm not gonna try to convince anyone of
my opinion not gonna come close to trying whatever
you wanna argue with me about in the comments i've
already heard it in person a gazillion times trust
me so go ahead leave it in the comments helps out
with the engagement of the video the films down
here that like i don't really care for or that i
don't like i can objectively see why people really
enjoy these films a lot of this is mainly coming
from just a purely emotional subjective state
of viewing experience is where i'm really coming
from there's a couple here though where i'm like
i don't understand yeah for all you guys who are
always like yeah that great guy he's he's he's
too mainstream and that's why i can't trust his
opinions well now i'm gonna have this video just
ready ready to share that that one or two comments
or if you already didn't trust my opinion then
this will only help to serve you and if you did
trust my opinion and now i'll have you question
my opinion hopefully that's the goal of today's
video is to question my whole character anyway
guys now let's just have some fun leave a like
kind of wish the dislike button was still visible
for videos like this just be a really amusing
effect to mental health thinking it'd be funny
at first but then i die slowly on the inside
all right guys number ten i love that i'm kicking
it off with this one this movie actually has
a pretty decent critic score on rotten tomatoes
but once i say you're gonna know for sure like
oh yeah yeah the audiences don't like this movie
i actually had a really fun time when i saw it and
that is ghostbusters 2016. go ahead type away
tell me everything you don't like about it i
don't care when i watched this film i actually
had a really great time i thought it was funny
i thought the main ensemble doesn't compare to
the original ensemble like this movie in total
does not compare to the original but
in terms of a remake in terms of a
comedy i would say that this is just fine that
it is a good time when i saw it i was laughing
i enjoyed the action i like chris hemsworth a lot
in the film does it have that problem that a lot
of judd apatow films have where it's like oh he
really let the actors just improvise a lot and
then they put it together in the editing room i
understand that's paul feig not joe at the time
judd comparison yeah it does have that issue but
the end product for me as someone who has a major
affinity for the first two ghostbusters films i
would say that i actually really enjoyed this one
quite a bit we're off to a strong start people
let's go on at number nine number nine a movie
that might seem weird to put on here at first
because it's actually a best picture winner and
by me saying that you might actually go oh i think
i know where greg's going with this yeah i mean
i only saw it one time i saw it in the theaters
and i was quite moved by it i was moved to tears
several times and that is the best picture
winner crash the movie that whenever people
talk about best picture winners they're
like what that movie would white what crazy
crush sucks i get it you know even when i was
younger i saw this one was like 14 years old when
i saw it in the theaters at that age even i had
moments of kind of feeling like there's an adult
talking at me instead of letting the characters
do real talking but i can't deny i think the
movie's emotion really clicked with me i was very
much movement i think the performances are very
strong you know what on a very personal note i saw
this when i was 14 years old i'm gonna get real
pretty real with you guys right now you know even
though i grew up of course knowing racism is wrong
even like in the school i had all my friends we
had like a tight-knit group of like 30 kids and
it was a diverse group of kids however i was still
surrounded by like a lot of adults even some kids
who had some thoughts that could only be deemed as
prejudice like they were some prejudice thoughts
and when you're that young a lot of time you don't
even realize that you're having thoughts that are
insensitive or that actually would be qualified
as prejudice and there's a scene in this movie and
it's always stuck with me and that is when sandra
bullock is having the locks change she's arguing
with brendan fraser and she's talking about the
guy changing their locks these gang bangers gonna
be giving the key out to his gangbanger friends
he's just profiling this guy and being completely
racist based off of the way he looks and at
the time of seeing that scene it made me cringe
because i knew people who thought that way and
it made me realize at 14 not thirty year old crap
fourteen you know actually that those thoughts
and fears and tension in my shoulders does come
into mind whenever i see someone who happens to
fit that description of what she's talking about
and from that moment on from that movie it made
me go i'm not going to think like that anymore
and then greg cured all of racism crash
saved racism that stopped it the movie
did its goal and now no more racism all
right number eight a classic a classic film
i think it's fine all right i don't dislike
it i i think it's i think it's very very fine
that's like the best i can go with it it's one
of those movies where i can watch it and go yes
i understand why you love it not for me so
much though raiders of the lost ark i think
out of the original trilogy of indiana jones
films it is the only one that i watch where i
actually tune out pretty much through a lot of
it when i am watching it are there things that
i appreciate about the film undoubtedly i do
think harrison ford does a good job i do like
uh karen allen i think some of the the practical
effects the rolling ball at the beginning yeah
it's all fun and exciting uh sure for the most
part though uh i don't find a lot of the plot
that entertaining i don't find the characters even
though the performances are good i don't find the
characters that intriguing i find the mystery the
puzzle solving a little dull the action is just
kind of okay to me for for most of the film yeah
it's just fine it's the best i got for it i'd much
rather watch temple to do all right i'm gonna put
number seven and six together just kind of decided
right now because i i'm pretty sure i got like the
same opinion about both these films these are two
classic horror movies that kick-started some of
the biggest horror franchises of all time i find
them extremely overrated especially one of them
that i often see as one of the greatest horror
films of all time the only way i can describe
this to you is uh um i i'm bored out of my [__]
mind when i watch these films that is halloween
and friday the 13th i've seen both these movies
countless times i've tried i've really tried to
get on board with them and i just can't do it
maybe it's my inability to transplant my body and
soul into the time period when this was released
before better versions of these movies came out
maybe that's debatable too like no those are
the best i don't think they're the best i think
that they are slow meandering the characters very
uninteresting i don't think they're scary i don't
think they're thrilling i don't think they're uh
schlockly amusing i i just find them really
really dull experiences i kind of like the
finales of both of them i kind of like them
but for the most part i always walk away going
i think that's very overrated and i'm not gonna
share this opinion with the group that i'm with
and if i'm being really honest with you from being
very real with y'all i think the halloween 2018
movie far surpasses the original and if i'm
gonna be really really really really honest
i think the halloween rob zombie version
is way more enjoyable the theatrical cut
i'm not a big fan of the director's cup and number
five here we go now i actually referenced this
movie when i was talking about the batman the few
qualities that i can say i i i like i appreciate i
would say the qualities of this movie that i saw
reflected in the batman was what made me happy
but the actual movie itself that i referenced i
don't understand why people my entire life have
said it's one of the greatest screenplays of
all time i've heard many filmmakers tours say
that this is the best script ever written often
hailed as one of the best movies of all time
and every time i watch it i always have to
divide up my viewing experience i can never
finish this in one sitting i even tried before
the batman to watch this in one sitting but i
can't do it i start to snooze i start to think
of different things i'm not even on my phone i'm
not one of those guys when watching a movie who's
on his phone it's the movie chinatown like i said
i'm not gonna convince anyone of why this movie
is a snooze fest but yeah i i am bored as hell
whenever i watch it and i think if more people
were honest with themselves they'd admit that too
all right number four this is the one i
think i have never been shy to admit of
how much i really liked this film like i'm
willing to die on this hill and i know i'm
vastly in the minority the star of
this movie pretty much disavows it
it kind of i kind of got the impression
that everyone involved tries to like
screw that movie genuinely considered like a
really terrible film and won a razzy for being
so bad but whenever i watch it i do not share that
sentiment it is not nostalgia i think we watched
it as an adult like a couple years ago and i still
went i don't understand i just it's one of those i
i just don't understand i don't understand why
why i'm one of the few people who has this opinion
i think it's a good movie wild wild west i
think it's really funny i love the chemistry
with will smith and kevin kline i think it's very
inventive i think it's a very creative movie kind
of is a little bit clunky in the beginning a lot
of people say it's clunky throughout but i think
in the beginning it's a little bit clunky but as
it progresses the time you get those two teamed up
i think it's funny zany i love some of the action
scenes a lot gadgets are really cool and again
the chemistry between those two i would
like more sci-fi westerns like this that
have just kind of a tongue-in-cheek aspect to it
so yeah i'd say wild wildsmith is an actual good
movie in this guy's opinion let's say
wildsmithing said wow wild smith i
apologize number three here we go star wars
fans listen up i'm willing to reignite this
debate you thought this debate was over no no
no let's get it going for another 10 more years
i think the last jedi is the best out of the
disney trilogy now even though in real life it has
not been the most shocking reaction from people
for me to say that undoubtedly this is the movie
i've had the most arguments with people about
arguments i never want to get into and then it
becomes one i'm like oh crap here i am i guess i'm
arguing and that's the last jedi i'm only gonna go
over a couple of things here i think ryan johnson
gets a lot of crap for this movie as you all
know i agree the poe dameron side of it not that
interesting the fin side of it very dull the rey
and luke skywalker and the kylo ren stuff for most
of that i actually really really enjoy it and the
luke skywalker portrayal here makes sense now when
i first saw this movie i said i loved it and i did
i meant it when i rewatched it when i watched the
films in release date order leading up to the rise
of skywalker it actually went down a couple like
quite a bit i was like oh you know maybe i don't
love this movie i like it though i still like it
a lot but i i don't love it the luke skywalker
thing is something i just i i can't seem to agree
with people on like i can i can understand i can
actually understand but when i watch this film i'm
like well ryan johnson didn't do the setup with
the force awakens like they had the first order
now in power kylo ren established as a guy who
fell to the dark side who was the nephew of luke
skywalker and was also a student of luke skywalker
so with the time you get to luke skywalker makes
sense why he would be the guy that he is this dude
who is so resistant towards everything that it
means to be a jedi i love the arc that he has in
that film and he gets a lot of [__] for that
one moment where he whips out his lightsaber
for i believe 0.5 seconds because he was tempted
but when i watch this movie i'm like he's human
he's a skywalker he's the son of darth vader it's
perfectly human to me that he would have a moment
where he's kind of tempted by i've seen some
darkness that may be oh maybe i should like do
something to remove it like i actually don't blame
him for that moment like i said i have heard it
all a billion times when i watch it i understand
the portrayal i understood what ryan johnson was
going for is it the best star wars film not
by a long shot but out of the disney trilogy
i actually feel like it's more than just nostalgia
bait i really like some of the things that it was
bold enough to actually explore and i like the art
that luke skywalker has boom i said it number two
is a movie that i should love i should love this
film this movie was designed for me i'm gonna
tell you what it is right now heat it took me
must have been my 20th time maybe watching this
movie to realize i have my whole life been
trying to convince myself that i actually
like this movie but i've been lying to myself this
whole time i don't really think i like this movie
slow burn crime dramas crime action films that's
like my main jam i know we mainly talk about like
comic books big ip's here but that's actually my
main jam when it comes to genre films also de niro
pacino massive de niro pacino fans especially when
i started watching this film when i was younger i
would literally create my own little cinematic
universe what i would do is that alternate it'd
be pacino film de niro pacino de niro pacino de
niro i'd watched their individual films and then
i would watch heat the culmination film of 30
years of waiting for these guys to come together
and yeah whenever i admit this to someone oh boy
that reaction is not pleasant i like the first 15
minutes of this film a lot like the opening heist
it feels like oh yeah the dark knight definitely
borrowed some tonality from it i like the first
15 minutes 20 minutes maybe i think de niro from
beginning to end is excellent the last half hour
can get on board with that first scene when they
do have their like the coffee shop scene together
where they do meet i enjoy that great acting
final heist great a lot about the finale i enjoy
and a lot about the beginning but keep in mind
it's a three hour movie so most of this movie i do
find i don't give a [__] about the characters a
little bit meandering a lot of mellow drama that
just does not click for me and really loses the
drive of this film i think everyone's doing a
good job like in terms of acting for the most
most people i think are doing a good job yet the
writing i just don't enjoy the storytelling of
most of these people it just plays like a soap
opera to me so much of the time instead of a
hard-hitting drama i'm just like god damn this is
taking [__] forever every time i watch it i just
try to like it but i had to be honest with myself
last time watch it like i don't really like this
movie even though everyone does a good job he's
still one of my favorite actors of all time but
god damn i i think al pacino's over-the-topness
in this film is just so obnoxious and annoying
great ass like every time i watch i'm like
there's there's no way this guy's a cop like
there's no way this guy is a cop i don't see
it it's the furthest thing from believable
and it's just way too over the top for me even
though i like the scenes he has with the nero
those very few ones for most part i find
his performance just incredibly distracting
and yeah i get it believe me i do i've listened
to a lot of think pieces about this film that
adore this movie yeah no but that's the point of
the film that's it's not just a straightforward
action thriller it's about diving into the
intimate lives like yeah the dinner pacino they're
the best at what they do but man their personal
lives are [__] up and everyone around them their
lives are really harsh too yeah all that stuff not
saying i couldn't do without it i just think the
execution of it does not click with me and uh i
i think it could have been shorter and could have
been written better because i'm just not moved
by vast majority of it all right guys number one
number one number one shouldn't be
number one the reason it's number one
is because more than what i
said about heat the second i say
when i'm about to state right now for you easily
leads into whoever i'm saying this to climbing
down my throat every single time you know what
it makes me think of it makes me think of that
family guy moment when peter admits i did not care
for the godfather what like i like this movie i do
i actually like this room that's why i don't think
it should be number one but no movie on this list
warrants the same reaction i tend to get
out of anyone i say this to here it is
i think captain america winter soldier is a little
overrated and that's usually how i present it i
just say it's a little overrated some people are
like the greatest action of all time like you had
some of the best action out of the mcu but is it
really some of the best action of all time like
i think of a bunch of movies that have just way
better action i like the action like especially
for an mcu film i do it's good i think it's a
solid plot political thriller when i'm watching
it i wouldn't say i'm bored my main thing is
is people are constantly hailing this movie
as the best mcu movie to have ever existed i
constantly hear it or number two but a lot of
time it's number one i think i liked it more the
first time i stopped whenever i've re-watched it
at home it's the same feeling while i enjoy it
while i think it's a good plot i don't really
care about the characters in this movie i never
really had an attachment to bucky leaning into
this i kind of cared about bucky more in civil war
actually they care about bucky a lot more in civil
war captain america natasha well good performers
just very straightforward and i'm i'm not that
engaged into whatever emotional journeys they're
going on in this film like when i think about this
movie even though i've seen it several times i do
kind of just flash to some of the action scenes
but like character moments or whatever they don't
really land a punch for me like good plot twist
the first time you watched it i just don't get hit
with that feeling of this is the most brilliant
thing out of the marvel cinematic universe the
number one reaction i get is people constantly
are telling me you're wrong you're wrong you're
wrong i don't even like really try just like i'm
just telling you for some reason just doesn't
fly with me for that that strong i like it i do
think it's a little overrated but it's just not
to me one of the top three favorites even from
from the mcu anyway guys well those are uh easily
my 10 most unpopular opinions what are your most
unpopular movie opinions what's the ones you get
the most crap for for either liking or disliking
leave it down in the comments below thank you
for engaging with me see you soon citizens